Hello world. It's Raj.
Welcome to this live stream.
I'm very excited to be here today. We're
going to generate some fake news. No,
I'm just kidding.
It's not fake news.
It is generated Wikipedia articles.
Okay?
That's what we're going to do today.
And uh,
I'm very excited for this because we
are finally going to code and Lstm from
scratch.
We are going to code an Lstm from scratch.
That means that we are doing it
from scratch, not num py, scratch,
but tensorflow scratch.
No care.
Os we're going to code out
the internals of an LSTM cell.
And here's what it's going to look like.
It's going to look like this. Okay?
It's going to look like this, just
like this. And we can see that, right?
Let me make the text a little bigger.
We can see that. Okay? So
we'll give it some input tax.
I plan to make the world a better
place by, and then it's going to, uh,
generate the rest of the text.
Now this is actually really bad because
it only took one iteration of training,
but it's gonna get better over time.
Okay? So that's what we're going to do.
And we are, we are, we are psyched
to do this. Thank you guys.
Hi everybody. Let's start with
our five minute Q and. A. Okay.
So ask me deep learning machine learning,
any kind of questions you want Ama,
go for it.
Yeah.
Oh, and we are, I am live at
the end. Please subscribe.
And if you want to see more live streams
there. Every Wednesday at 10:00 AM pst,
also at the upload Vr studios with
the wizard of Oz, Oz. Balaban. Ian,
who was going to be up there.
There he is.
He's going to be the
voice of God later on.
He's going to help me answer questions.
Okay. So ask me some questions.
We're going to get started.
We're going to do some virtual reality
today to virtual reality, to, to demos,
to math as well.
Hi,
Palosh Mohan Leo Party Tuber.
Okay.
Questions?
Can you explain more on the text?
Summarizer the tech summarizer was,
um,
an LSTM network that you
use memory and attention.
And this next weekly video that's
coming out in three days will definitely
explain that more. Okay.
Uh, come to Brazil someday.
Someday I want to go to Brazil.
What is best machine learning?
I love that question. This channel,
could you train an Lstm with a chat bot?
Yes. Could you train a chat Bot with
an Lstm is what you meant to say?
The answer is yes,
you can.
What's your opinion about semantic
web? Semantic web? The cement.
The semantic web is a word that describes
the web of words and the web of text
and it's all really connected in there.
It's hyperlinked together.
We still have to improve right now.
Links go one way but we
want links to go both ways,
which was the original vision for the web.
Zana do was a project
that did that and IPFS.
The interplanetary file system
is aiming to go back to that,
so check out that protocol. Will
you use syntax net? Not In this.
We not using transfer learning.
We are building it from
scratch as a learning exercise.
Why do you do not use chaos?
Because we want to learn all of it.
Thank you for joining the class and
you'd Udacity. Thanks King Burrito.
Best framework for sound processing
in python for sound processing fun.
There are quite a lot,
um,
for sound processing
Dirac the IRA c is a good one, uh,
to, it's by a German, a programmer.
What harp hardware do you recommend? Have
you tried FPG A's for deep learning? Uh,
Nvidia is a good g as a good brand
for Gpu, specifically the Titan X.
Although if I were to say, you
know, between cloud and local,
I would choose the cloud specifically AWS.
What is your background in mathematics
or Raj? I took some math in high school.
I took some math in college.
Uh, I takes, took some math
online. You're really, it's,
it's, we have to think about this
as a lifelong learning process.
I'm still learning math. It's not like I
just stopped learning math and now I'm,
I'm good to go.
We need to switch the view from a PR,
from learning being a period in our
lives to a lifelong learning process.
So I've studied linear Algebra and
Calculus and Statistics and I'm still
studying these things.
Two more questions and then the five
minutes is up and we're going to code this
thing. Okay. The second
question, the first question is,
well, you make an AI robot in
future, like personal assistant,
personal assistant, uh, w I, yes,
I have several chat bot
videos in terms of hardware.
So hardware is a little more
effort than just software.
I definitely want to do more
hardware and I will, uh,
let me just finish this course
first and then you know,
a lot of crazy cool things will,
will start coming out.
One more question and then we're going
to get started with the code. This,
the next question is
how can I get out of Venezuela with AI?
Okay.
Wow. I don't know. Okay. No,
here's how you do it.
You would just study this stuff well
enough that one of these big companies
would want to hire you and host you.
So just study it well enough.
You can do it in Venezuela, you can do
it in Africa, you can do it anywhere.
You can become a world class machine
learning expert anywhere in the world
because of the Internet.
So get good at this stuff.
People will want you increase
your personal value and
people will want you and
you can go anywhere you want. The
barriers to entry to travel will decrease.
That's it for the questions. Now we're
going to get started with this code. Okay,
let's get started with the code.
So what we're gonna do is we're going
to generate text and we're going to
generate Wikipedia articles. Okay?
And by the way, with the questions,
I'm not going to let
it interrupt my coding,
so I'm going to code for something
like 15 minutes and then go back to the
questions and then we'll just
repeat that process. Okay.
I was reading feedback from last
time and I want to better, so let's,
we're going to code some,
we're going to generate some text
from in the style of Wikipedia. Okay?
That's what we're going to do.
So let's look at the data
set that we're going to use.
This is the data set and by the way,
check the check the video description
for a link to the get hub repository.
And I'm going to use VR by the
way, to show some math. So it's,
so stay tuned for that. Okay.
So that's what we're gonna do.
And uh,
okay, so let's get started with this. This
is the Dataset that we're going to use.
It is from salesforce, Matt and mine. So
metamind got bought out by salesforce.
Great purchase. Metamind had some
really great technology. And by the way,
if you start an AI startup,
you will
very likely to get bought out
if you bring any sort of value.
These big companies are snatching
up AI startups like they are candy,
like they are candies.
So it is a good time to be an AI
right now is a very lucrative time.
This dataset is a collection of 100
million tokens preprocessed for us from
Wikipedia articles. So they took a bunch
of Wikipedia articles, tokenize them,
and then they, uh, this is the Dataset.
So this is the data set we're going
to use to train our model on, okay,
that's our dataset.
Let's get started.
The first thing we're
going to do is import our
dependencies, dependencies, time.
What are the dependencies that we need?
Well,
of course we need num
Pi for vectorization.
We want to vectorize our data
before we feed it into our model.
The next step is to import,
uh, the art shows to map.
The next step is to import random. Okay,
and why are we going to import random?
We want to generate a po probability
distribution, right? For generating texts.
This is going to help us generate text.
Uh,
the next is tensorflow
from machine learning.
And then finally we have one more
and that is a date time, date,
time. Okay. So this is going to show,
this is for clocking the training time.
We want to see, you know, where we
are in the training process. Okay?
So that's it for our dependencies.
And now we're going to open our text.
So let's check out this text.
It's going to be,
so I've already downloaded it and
here's, here it is, by the way, uh,
this is the one that you should
download. Where is it? It is right here.
This one?
Yeah,
right here. The 4.3 megs. Okay.
Oh, actually no. The one 81 mags.
Do you want more data? So download the
one 81 megs. It's an a. Dot. Raw increase.
The font size, I can
do that. It's in a dot.
Raw.
How's that? That's amazing. I am very
excited for this. Okay. It's an a. Dot.
Raw format.
So that's gonna be Wiki Dot Texstar raw.
So I've already downloaded it and
it's right in my folder right here.
So I'll say Wiki Tex.
Dot. Raw Dot Reed. Okay,
so that's our dataset.
And we're going to print out the length
of the text that we have so far in the
number of characters.
And it's going to be,
it's going to show show
how long this text is.
And then we want to print
the head of the tax.
We're just going to show
the first collection of
characters, just so you know,
for ourselves.
And is the great thing about having a
Jupiter notebook is that we can just say
how much do we want? And I'm going to
say I want the first thousand tokens.
So let's see if this prince
out and it will for sure,
definitely pronounced. Okay. So we
have how many characters we have.
We have 128 no, we have 1
million, 1.2 million characters.
We have a lot of characters.
And we're going to print this out.
Okay.
Character by character.
And in fact we are going to
feed characters into our model.
We're going to feed
characters into a model.
So it's going to be character by
character training and then character by
character output. And we're going
to talk about ways to improve that.
Okay? So that's, that's
that's it for our tax,
that's what the text we're going to use.
And these are Wikipedia articles
that are already tokenized.
That means that each word is it's
own token. It's its own string.
And this is good for this is
this our preprocessing steps.
So now we're going to
print out the characters.
So now we want to print out our characters
and sort them and sort them as well.
That should be reversed. So our
characters are going to be sorted. Okay.
We want to sort them.
Python has some great native functions
for sorting characters. And, uh,
so this is actually a nested,
it was, it wasn't my AI, it was, it
was the wizard of Oz. He added that.
So that was good. I was kind
of surprised. I was like, whoa.
But eventually it will be an AI.
So now we have charts size,
which is going to be the
length of the characters.
And then we want to print
out the number of care.
So this is an exercise to show the
characters that we're going to be dealing
with.
This is very important because we want
to show the characters that we're going
to be dealing with here.
Okay?
So we have our charge size and we
want to print out all of this chars.
And then lastly, we want to say we
don't even need to print. Hello. Okay.
So here's what's going to happen.
Hold on.
So we have sorted let would it,
oh,
there we go.
Okay. We have 259 characters
total. So what did we do?
You just do a set is an unordered
collection with no duplicate elements.
So we first remove duplicates,
then we uh,
and then we turn it back into a list.
Okay. And then we sorted the list.
And so it's sorted Alpha numerically.
Uh,
please post the link. Yes, the wizard
of article posts a link on my behalf.
And so these are our characters sorted
alphanumerically all of these are the
character of the are the characters are,
we're going to use 259 unique characters,
sorry.
And the link to that,
I'm going to post that in the chat room.
Here's the link to the Dataset.
So that's it for our characters.
And now
there we go.
So that's it for our characters.
So we saw a little bit of
data preprocessing and then
we're going to get to the
machine learning.
So now we want to have a method
to convert characters to ids.
Why?
Because it's,
it's good to have this mapping because
we're going to need it to create labels.
And I'll talk about specifically
what we're considering labels, right?
Th the labels here aren't so clear cut.
They're not like ones or Zeros.
We just have a collection of
characters. What are the labels? Well,
we'll hold on tight. We're going to figure
out exactly what that is in a second.
So we'll start off with
creating a dictionary to
convert our characters to ids.
And we're going to enumerate through all
of those characters to create ids for
each of them. So these are
dictionary objects. Okay?
These are dictionary objects and
I can just paste this in again,
but this time it's going
to be id to character.
So these two functions are going to
convert our characters to ids and vice
versa. Okay? And that's
what that's going to do.
Make sure I have all of that.
Their character or characters.
Yep, Yep, Yep, Yep, Yep.
There's something missing
here. There we go. Okay.
So that's our character to ids
isn't gonna convert character.
So [inaudible] and bias and
numer in new arrayed, right?
Spelling is such a bee spelling as a B.
Okay?
So that's what we're going to do.
So now we're going to
create this helper method.
So this helper method is going to,
uh,
generates the probability of each
character of each next character.
Okay? So this is going to help us generate
the probability of each next care.
So character by character,
we're going to predict a character,
and then we're gonna
generate the next character.
So we're going to our
model output a character,
and we want to generate
the next character.
So this is going to be a helper method
and what's claimed more as we go.
So we're going to say sample. So given
a prediction. So the prediction is,
uh,
it is a list of the prediction is going
to be a list of possible characters.
And this method is going to return the,
the,
the most likely character.
So it's actually a list of characters
that were in that we're going to input.
And then we're going to use this method
to predict what is the most likely of
those characters.
So it's a multi-class classification
problem where the classes themselves are
characters. This is gonna make more sense
once we start building the model. Okay?
So we have samples. Okay. So the first
thing we're going to do is want to say
random dot uniform
zero through one.
And so this is going to generate a,
a uniform distribution okay.
Through the interview interval of
zero to one. Why to, okay. So yeah,
I was going to say we
have Socratic Mishra,
a Jew all Daya and get the nerves
run and asking why two dictionaries,
why do you need to use two of them?
Okay,
so we're using two dictionaries
because we want to convert characters,
two ids and to characters.
And the reason for this is
we want a way to encode, uh,
these characters because we want to,
first,
we want to convert the
characters to ids so that, uh,
we can convert them back
later. And this is for, uh,
it's for indexing. We need a way
to index these characters, right?
More than just a, B, c, d, e.
We need an a numeric way of indexing
these characters so we can refer to them.
We want to store and retrieve
them optimally. So this is a way,
this is a way for us to index them similar
to a, you know, it's a key value pair,
right?
So the,
the character id is going to be
the length of the prediction.
Minus one,
because,
uh, because, uh,
since the length is greater than
the indices starting at zero.
So that's what we add a minus one
at the end. So we want to generate,
so we have a list of a
prediction predicted characters.
We have a list of predicted characters,
uh,
and uh,
we want to say, so for each
character prediction probability.
So for each of them. So we're going
to iterate through each of these
predictions.
Okay.
So we're going to iterate through
the length of the prediction list.
This is a list of possible characters,
probabilities.
It's a list of possible
character probabilities.
And we want to say for each of
them, let's, let's, uh, first say,
so as is going to store
the prediction character.
So there's going to store
prediction character.
And
um,
so we're going to say
this is our first character. This is
our first prediction. And now this is,
this is where the unit, this is where
the distribution, uh, comes into play.
We're going to say if s is
greater than or equal to r,
and so our is going to be a randomly
generated probability. Okay.
So we are generating a probability and
there are different ways of doing this.
But right now we are going to
randomly generate p probability. Okay?
And uh,
okay.
So if the, if it, if it's
greater. So that means if the, if,
if it's a likely probabilities.
So this is a generated threshold.
If it's greater than that,
then we're going to say, okay,
so this is the most likely character.
Set it to the character id.
Okay? And then we're going to break.
And so once we have that character,
once we have that likely character,
we want to one hot encoding, okay,
we want to generate a character.
So we want to create,
create a one hot encoding
of that character.
So we're going to use a num Pi to do this.
And so let me talk about what
one hot encoding is. Why are we,
why are we one hot encoding
these characters? Okay.
We are one hot encoding these
characters because, let me it.
So it's going to be,
we're going to one hot and code
these characters because we want to,
one hot encoding is a way for us to
differentiate. So if we could say, uh,
uh, we went to differentiate
not ranked value. So you know,
if we,
if we were to say,
if we were to just normally
encode like fish taco Bob Geyser,
we could, you know, if we were to encode
this, normally it can be one, two, three,
four. But the problem with that
is that gives them a ranking.
We don't care about her
ranking Taco because it's too,
is not somehow greater than fish.
These are just values. Okay.
So one hot encoding is a way for us to
differentiate between different values
without ranking them.
And so we want to differentiate between
these values without ranking them.
And One hot encoding looks more like this,
you know,
they're just as collection of ones
and Zeros, it's just like that.
And so to do that will generate,
will create a zero matrix with non Pi's
zero function with the size of the jar
size. And then we're going to say, uh,
at the specify character index, set
it to one, so it's gonna be like zero.
This is a drought one. There's there
where one is the index of that character.
Okay.
That's it for our sample probability
distribution.
So hill at averse shopper asking what
if you're using two dictionaries will be
very inefficient if you're
using a big dataset a and e
or would it take forever?
May Basically, uh,
well we actually see a lot of in memory
storage for big data sets and the no,
so the answer is no, because
why? Because we want to a cue,
it could be if we start it all in memory,
but we are,
we are storing it in batches. So we are
flushing it, we're flushing the cache.
This is our cash story and we're,
we're going to flush it every so often
during training. So, but great question.
And, and, and, and another
way, great way to do this,
if you don't want to have to flush
it, uh, is to store it on disk.
And for that we can just,
uh, we could, I mean, it's,
it's a trade off because if
we didn't store it in memory,
we would be a continuously retrieving
it. So then there's that, uh,
computational complexity.
So you're trading off memory
verses computation time for,
for continuously reading it
from disk. Right. Every time.
Uh,
so which one would be the best?
I would say to do it in memory but then
to flush, but to flush it every so often.
Okay.
Okay. So that's, that's one hot
encoding. Okay. So that's for our sample.
Okay.
Okay. So now we're going to vectorize our
data before we feed it into our model.
So vectorize our data. Okay. We
are just chugging along here.
We're going to vectorize our data
to feed it into the model. Okay.
So the length per section. So these
are, I'm going to first define art,
some variables here.
So the length per section is the size
of what we can consider sentence a
sentence. This is how we're going
to feed data into the model.
They're going to be 50 character long,
uh,
batches.
And then each of those batches,
those characters are what's going
to go directly into the model.
But the size of these batches
are 50 characters long. Okay.
And then I'm going to say
skip because we're going to,
okay.
I'll show you exactly what I'm
using. Skip in a second. Okay.
And then we're going to create
an empty list, four sections.
And then for next characters.
Okay.
So,
so that's that. Okay. So
here's why we use skip.
So what we're gonna do is we're
going to fill this section's list.
We want to fill the sections list with
chunks of tax. So every two characters,
we want to create a new
50 character long section.
So if it was something like this, so
okay, that's no. So if our tech was like,
hello, I am [inaudible] Raj, this would
generate something like, you know,
uh, so start off with, hello, I'm Sarah.
There'll be the first one and then it
will skip to, and then we'll say low,
I am Saroj whatever's next
because, and then skip to, so then,
oh, I am Saroj because more, right?
So it's going to keep generating
these texts and these,
these chunks are overlapping
there overlapping chunks.
And there are different
ways we could feed them in.
We don't have to have them overlap.
We can have them all be unique.
But in this case we're going to have them
overlap because we don't have a lot of
data. So we want to reuse some
of the data if we can. Okay.
Does that mean that our model is going
to be less accurate than we were if we
were to give it just only unique taxed?
Yes, it will be less accurate then we,
if we were to give it just unique taxed,
but uh,
we don't have shitloads of computing
power, so we're going to do that.
So now let's, let's do
this. So we're going to,
we're going to do this.
So we're going to generate,
so we're going to iterate
through, uh, are taxed.
We're going to iterate through our text,
skipping where we need to skip and we're
going to upend the sections list by
saying, okay, so our text,
okay,
we're going to Upenn or sections
in our next characters list.
You're good.
Okay.
So then our next check characters
were good to compend text hi.
Plus length per section.
So we're filling the,
the sections with those chunks of texts
and the next character is with the next
character.
Exactly. So these are,
this is us cure. No Siri,
I hate Siri. Siri is such a terrible
assistant. So we're going to say,
so now that we have these
chunks that I just described,
we're going to vectorize them.
So now to vectorize them,
we're going to use non pies.
Opening bracket needed for a list.
Hold on
text, hold on. So zero length text.
Okay.
Minus length per section. Skip
text sections. Dot. Append.
Hold on. Text. Let me
just, this is actually,
this should be something else.
It should be,
hold on,
hold on.
So yeah,
sections dot.
Upenn should actually be the text I
apparently there's a missing bracket that
our bond and Tom are saying.
Thank you. Thank you guys.
Text and then the next
characters. Dot append text. Hi.
Length per section.
Okay,
so w so that's it. Oh no wait,
wait, wait. You're mic.
Your mic just went off.
Awesome.
One second.
We're going to switch over one second.
One Sec.
Are we gonna switch minds? I don't want,
I'm just going to switch the battery.
I think that'll be quicker because it
really, I mean it's still worth your side.
Just went out my side. I think we're good.
And Five, four, three, two, one.
And we're back. We're back.
We're back. We're back. Okay,
great. Okay, so where was I?
So we're going to vectorize these inputs.
Okay.
We're going to vectorize these inputs.
So to do that, we're going to say, okay,
x equals Pi none.
Pi Dot Zeros and
God, Damn, this is compact code. Okay.
Length of the sections.
Okay.
We need to get to the machine learning.
So what I'm gonna do is a paste it from
here and then explain it right here.
We need to get to the machine learning.
Okay,
we're going to vectorize
our inputs and outputs.
They're going to both be zero
matrices that are going to be the,
so it's going to be this length of the
sections by the length per section,
by the length PR, uh, by the
length per section. Yes, exactly.
So, and then, so what are our
labels? What are our labels?
Are labels are going to be the next
character. So we're creating labels.
Each of our predictions is going to have
a label and the label is going to be
the next character. Okay, so,
so when we have an output,
our output is going to be
our predicted next character.
That's going to be our output label and
the actual label was going to be the
real next character.
So given some character in our sentence
like you know for the word thaw for h,
the next word we know is he,
so the label is going to be e but are
predicting next character is going to be z
and w. And so this goes back
to that initial question,
why convert a charge to ids?
We need to wait an Alpha knew we need
a numeric way of representing these
because we want to minimize our loss and
our loss function is going to minimize
the distance between our predicted
character slash label and our actual next
character. Slash. Label. Okay, so
that's what our labels are in this case.
So we have someone pointing out
that range is misspelled actually.
Um, he is saying that there's a Typo
in range above the function definition.
Thank you. Above the function
definition ranges. Misspelled. Okay,
so range is
mm,
range is, it says R,N
a.G instead of r a n. G.
E maybe you can control
off it or something.
R A. N. G. O. R. N. A. G. A. G. No. Hmm.
Okay. No, I fixed that. Don't
worry about it. We're okay. Okay.
So now we're getting to the
machine learning. Guys. Let's,
let's do this. Get Ready,
get ready. We're about to do some machine
learning. Get ready for this. Okay.
And we're going to add
some VR into the mix. Guys.
We're going to add some VR into the mix.
This is the shit right now.
This is the shit. Here we go. So
the first thing, so machine learning
time.
Okay.
So here we go.
So the first thing we want to do is we
want to define our batch size. So how,
so in the in general,
let's talk about these terminologies.
They are continuously
used in machine learning.
The batch side defines the
number of samples that are
going to be propagated, uh,
uh, through the network. So, and
then one. And so we have batches.
We have epochs and then we have um,
iterations.
So for one epoch is going to be one
forward pass and one backward pass.
And of all the training samples,
the bad sides is a number of training
samples in one forward, backward pass.
So the higher the batch size,
the more memory space we'll need.
Okay.
So the more memory space we'll need.
And so
it's ready to go when we are. Okay, cool.
Thanks. We're about to do some PR. So,
and then to show line numbers.
Someone shout how to show
line numbers in a second.
Showmen shout out if this guy wants
to know, well I code this out.
So we have batch sizes, five
12, that's the bad size.
And now we're going to define the number
of iterations, the number of iterations.
How many do we want to have?
Let's say 72,000 why 72,000 uh,
we could have 70,000 we don't actually
have a lot of, because I don't have,
I'm not running this in the cloud.
I'm running this locally.
Okay.
So we've vectorize or input because
we want to feed them into our model.
We always have to vectorize our data
before we feed it into our model.
It's a way of converting it into
vectors slashed. Tensors okay,
so now what we're going to
do is we're going to say,
how often do we want to log while
let's log every 100 steps. Okay? Oh,
so and so why did I set 72,000 or
70,000 because we don't have a lot of
computing power.
So that's how often we want to log.
Like where we are just for
printing. So you know, we'll,
during our training iteration, we'll
use this as a checkpoint to say, okay,
now time to print something out.
Okay, so now we have saved every,
and so how often do we want to
save our model? This is also a, a,
an important thing.
We want to continuously save our model
so we don't lose where we are in time.
Okay? And now we want to say, how
many hidden nodes do we want to have?
So I'm going to say ten one hundred
and twenty four why 1024 well,
when we're choosing our hidden knows,
if we have too few,
then we result in under fitting.
That means our model doesn't
have enough data to general.
It doesn't have enough
general generalized storage.
It's a hasn't stored enough generalized
vectors from what it's trained on.
But if we have too many hit hidden nodes,
then we're going to going
to overfit because it's to
fit to the data and it's be
able to generalize well to other data.
So we have to have that ideal number
of hidden notes and there's actually a
formula for calculating the ideal
number of hidden nodes and you take into
account the number of input nodes
and the number of output nodes.
But right now we're going to choose
1,024 because it's in that range. Okay,
so let's give it some starting texts.
What does that text that
we want to train it on?
Some initial texts from which it
generates an entire article from,
so the starting text is going to be
okay.
I am thinking that that's
our starting text. Okay.
That's what we're going
to generate data from.
Okay. So that's that.
And so now we're going to
say
that's our starting texts.
Okay.
Oh was so I'll call it test texts. Start
Test Star. That's what I'll call it.
And so now we're going to save our model,
our model.
And so we wanted to find a checkpoint
directory. So intenser flow,
we define checkpoints
and checkpoints are just,
they are flags. That's
that, that define how uh,
where,
where in the training process we are.
So ideally we want several checkpoints so
we can, you know, depending on, you know,
just for testing purposes,
for debugging purposes,
obviously the last checkpoint is
going to be the where we want.
That's the model we want to
use is the fully trained model.
And so this is actually some,
uh,
do you have a second for questions? I
have a second for questions. So, um,
who do all is thing in this games,
there'll be too much data and
held to be held in weights,
will want it slow down.
Our processing.
And Sahil is asking how did you find
the right number of hidden nodes?
That is a great question. So heal is
killing it with this questions today.
Okay, so the question was, hold on.
Okay, great. That they can pop up.
Say it again. So, so he'll uh,
was asking how did you find the
right number of hidden nodes?
And you want to go with that?
Okay, that's a good one. Okay.
So the number of hidden nodes, so
calculating the, the hidden nodes.
So there's a formula towards the
formula. The formula is, okay,
so this is a great one right here. Hold
on. Where's the formula? This right here.
So check this out.
Okay.
There's for supervised learning,
which is what we're doing
because we have labels,
we are creating those labels ourselves.
Those labels are the next set of
characters and this formula where n is the
number of input neurons and, and the
next one is the number of output neurons,
number of the number of samples in the
training data set and some arbitrary
scaling factor.
If we were to use this formula,
this would give us a good estimate for
what our head notes should be. Okay.
And this. So hopefully that
answers your question. So back to
this.
So now
let's build this model we're going to
build LSTM and we're about to use VR in
is, I'll tell, I'll let you know.
I'll let you know. I'll let you know.
I'll let you know. So let's build
our model. So let's create our graph,
our computation graph. And in tensorflow
we always initialize a graph like this.
And then
we're going to say with graph.as default,
why?
Why as default?
This is our computation graph because
if we had multiple glip graphs,
this is a way for us to define which
graph. If we could say graph has default,
and then the identifier
for this graph is default,
the identify for the next graph.
But in this case we just have one graph.
Having multiple graphs
is not where we are. Now.
We don't actually need to run multiple
Grad, we just need one graph. Okay,
so is there no,
is there another link that they should
be a link to apart from the Dataset?
Uh, yes. So let me, let me
type that in. What did I just,
and the, and I'll put in a description as
well for, I just pasted it. Cool. Oh, so,
okay. So then, so we're
going to define us.
The first thing that we build our model
is we want you to find our global stats.
Okay. We wanted to find our global steps.
So our global step, our global step is,
refers to the number of batches
that are seen by the graph.
So every time a batch has provided,
the weights are updated in the
direction that minimizes the loss.
And global step just keeps track of
the number of batches seen so far.
So we're going to start off as a
zero, okay. And it's going to be, hey,
tensorflow variable,
uh,
because variables are tensorflow
primitives that can be modified and we are
going to modify it,
okay.
Because we're going to add to
it as opposed to a t. F. Dot.
Constant that never gets modified.
Those are immutable primitives.
So let's build the shit out of this.
So the first thing we're gonna
do is we're going to say,
let's define our placeholder.
So are placeholders are
our gateways for our data.
And these are going to be float 30
twos because they are 32 bit integers.
And we're going to say we're
going to define this tensor size.
So the tense or size, it's going
to be three dimensional. Okay.
It's going to be three dimensional
because we have three parameters for it.
This is the size of the tea, the data
that we're going to feed in to our model.
Okay. And so to define this,
let me define both. Uh,
gateways. We have two
place holders, right?
One for our data and
then one for our labels.
They're both going to be
32 bit integers and uh,
the size of this one.
So here's how it goes down.
Our data is going to be those character,
a 50 length character,
uh,
sentences that we are creating and our
labels are going to be the likely next
character. A list of a likely next
characters, no, sorry, not sorry.
Wrong.
Our labels are going to be the actual
next characters depending on given our
sentence. What does that next character,
the, the, the, the actual next character.
We want to predict the next character.
So the labels are there for us to
treat this as a classification problem.
That's what they're there for.
So now that we have that,
we're going to build our LSTM network.
This is what I've been waiting for.
We're going to build this LSTM network.
So let me show you this shit.
Okay,
we're going to build this LSTM network
and I have a great link to show you guys
if I can find it. So here's the
link. I'm going to paste it in here.
Here's the link and I'm going
to look at it on my screen.
Where did I say it?
Where's the link? No, hold
on. Where his, that plank.
Hold on. I got this. Did I
say it here? No, I didn't.
Oh
No. So this is actually a better LSTM
cell. Look. Let's just say LSTM network.
Check this out and then we're
going to go into VR in a second.
Here it is
an LSTM network and this is just,
this shows it through time. That's,
that's why we have, that's why
we have two of them side by side,
because it's showing it through time. So
if we were to just split this, in fact,
I can just split it myself.
Okay.
That's an LSTM network right there
through time.
So let me, let me actually just write
this down and do our get ready for VR.
Get ready for Vr.
Here we go.
Okay. Okay. So
let's do this in Vr.
So let's the womb,
we are now in virtual reality.
We are now in virtual reality. Okay.
Here's what it is. So let me see this.
Okay, great. So Undo. Yup.
Nope. Here is us one to many. This
one, yes. To and do that. Okay.
So here's what it is.
We are,
so if you could get switched to
the bass. Okay, great. Okay. Yeah.
So this is an LSTM cell, right?
And we can think of it as a box.
So an Lstm cell that's really all in a,
an an LSTM recurrent network.
The LSTM cell is, is uh, the neuron. It's,
it is that neuron, right? So when we
feed data into an LSTM recurrent network,
this is the neuron. So we have an
input gate, an output gate, uh,
forget gate.
So we'll say Aye.
Uh Oh
f and then we have an internal hidden
state, which we'll define as h.
And so the reason I'm doing
this in Vr is because,
and this represents the copy of it.
So this is copy one, this is two,
this is three.
And so what happens is
through time we update this.
So we back propagate through
time with this. And so what do,
I mean each of these gates
has a series of weight values.
So each of these has a
series of wait values. Okay.
And these weight values are
going to be updated through time.
And we have a standard,
we have a set,
a set of equations that we perform every
time to calculate a what this hidden
state is going to be.
LSTS are a way for us to capture
longterm dependencies for us to capture
longterm memory. And when
we back propagate through
time, we are updating the,
the state of the cell.
Okay.
And that's what I mean by through
time because as we add new batches,
new sentences, ah, we are
feeding in, not just uh,
the new data we are feeding in
the previous state of the STM. We,
we're pre fitting in the
previous state of the LSTM.
It's just going to back propagate through
time for as many iterations as we have.
Okay. And we're going to, we're
going to do that right now.
We're going to define all of these
gates programmatically. Okay.
So that's it for Vr. I hope you guys
liked that little VR demo. That was cool.
Let's see. Oh, we're really excited
about it. Oh, that's awesome. Okay,
I'm glad you guys liked the VR. Okay.
So that's for the, that's it for the VR.
Let's get back to the code.
So
I'm glad you guys liked that.
So here we go with the code. So
here we go. So let's
define our, uh, gates.
So we have our input gate,
our output gates and hour
we're going to or have our implicate
our Applegate, uh, and our, uh,
forget the gates as well
as our internal state.
So these are going to be calculated.
They will be calculated.
Um,
they will be calculated first.
Uh,
uh, they're not related to each other.
They're going to be calculated in, uh,
like, what's the word I'm trying
to look for it like siphons.
They're going to be calculated in vacuums,
vacuums,
there'll be calculated in vacuums.
And then we're going to,
then we're going to add it out.
So here's what I mean by that.
So let's write out the first thing,
the first side of weights,
and then we'll write out the next one.
So we're going to have a TF variable
to represent this, this value, okay.
Because the why, because these
are mutable, mutable, primitive.
And so the TF dot. Truncated
normal method, we'll define, uh,
it's going to define
a random distribution.
So we're going to initialize these
weights randomly as we do in network.
In neural nets. We start off with a random
distribution, uh, and this, and the,
this is going to be our
char,
char size and our hidden nodes.
And then this is our mean
and standard deviation.
So these are values that define,
yeah,
how that distribution is going
to look like. So remember it's a,
it's a distribution, like a golf
Sian, right? It's a distribution.
So we're going to generate those
weights randomly. So that's the weights.
And so I'm going to define this.
Don't worry, don't worry about it.
I'm going to define it.
So we have our starting weights and
then we have our next set of weights.
And so our next set of way I can
just actually copy and paste this.
Our next set of weights,
let me just,
it's going to be three lines of code and
then I'm going explain it. So TF dot.
Truncated normal of hidden
nodes and then of hidden nodes,
that distribution. And then lastly, our
bias. So this is going to happen for
are uh, input gates. This
is our input gate. Okay.
So this is our input gate.
This is,
this is the low level guys.
This is the low level right now.
So we have our bias.
So remember,
think of each of these as a perceptron.
These are neural nets
in and of themselves.
We have neural nets inside of a neural
net neuroception, basically neuroception.
So
okay,
here's what it is. Here's
what I have. Just coat it.
What I've just coded is the input gate.
So the input gate has,
mmm.
The implicate has the, uh,
what was I trying to say?
The input gate has the
weights, um, and it has,
it has an initial set of weights for the
input and then has waits for the output
and then has a bias
vector. Okay. So it has,
it has an initial set of weights and then
un UN un UN outputs that have weights
and then a bias vector. And guess
what, these are calculated in vacuum.
So none of these have anything
to do with each other yet.
We're just initializing them.
So let me,
let me just say this three
times or three more times.
So this is going to be the input.
This is going to be our,
forget where the weights for the input
and the wait for the previous output.
So let me say this.
So the weights for inputs then waits
for previous output as well as bias.
All hail the input gate. We have our
implicate. So now that's our implicate.
And so now we're going to
define our for decades.
Okay,
you guys are champs for sticking
through this because this is some,
this is some good stuff. Forget gate.
And then we have our health book gate.
We have our output gate,
we have zero Roi.
And then we have uh oh and then I,
and then see I,
this is us, our way of, of um,
this our memory cell. This is the,
the internal hidden state.
Oh,
and we're going to get into
those calculations in a second.
We are just defining these gates. That's
all we're doing. We're defining gates.
Gates have to be defined.
Bill Gates doesn't need to be defined.
He's already defined by Microsoft.
So we have our memory cell and
the rest of our gates. So we,
we've named them all respectively.
There are unique names and let me make
sure that the values inside of them are
good to go.
They are good to go because they are
there are initialize the same way.
They're initialized the same way.
All of them. Okay. So yes. Great.
Those are our cells. And oh wait, hold on.
Input.
Forget how put,
and lastly cell states,
those are our,
those are our, I will definitely
do an outline at the end.
Yeah,
the eye is duplicating. Thank you. Okay,
so now let's, let's calculate the cell.
We've defined them. So this is the actual
cell. This is how we define ourselves.
And
these are calculated separately.
No overlap until we get to this.
And so let me paste this part because I
need to explain what is going on here.
Okay? So here's what's going on.
Here's what, here's what the deal is.
Let me make sure it's all visible
because we're about to explain this shit.
Okay.
Oh, don't hold your borrower says hold
your horses. No, that's a duplicate.
That's a duplicate and no, no,
no, that's very useful actually.
I wrote that because it's very
useful. Okay, so here's what it is.
Here's what it is.
We are calculus. So, so here,
here are the equations by the way.
So these are the set of equations
and this is their programmatic.
These are the set of equations
for calculating our, what
do we want to calculate?
We want to calculate an output and a
state and we're going to answer some
questions. Go for on. Not a question
actually there seeing the W io. Uh,
you have the, you have a twice instead
of it should be w underscores CEO.
Thank you. Great. We are,
these are the,
and I linked to this before.
These are the set of equations and
I know it can be a little confusing.
This is math terminology. You have to do
a little bit of, you know, refreshing.
We're not sitting here doing
Algebra homework every day, right?
So of course we're going to need a
little bit of refreshing. It's okay.
These are just, uh, they're just, this
is a language. Math is a language.
We want to remember this language and
how do we remember the language by
practicing it? Okay, so this
is the language. Okay. The,
these are the set of equations that it's
going to calculate our output state.
And this is how this is what it's
represented. Like programmatically. No.
So I prefer programmatic implementations
to the a and the link is going to
happen in the, in the chat. I link to
it before, but it is in the description.
All the links are in the chat
and the description. Yes. Thanks.
[inaudible] wizard of Oz. So
that's what, that's what we did.
And this is the LSTM cell.
Okay.
So what we're gonna do is we're
going to matrix multiply the,
which is essentially a dot product.
We're going to multiply the input times
the input weights plus the output times
the weight for the previous
output plus the bias.
And the bias is our anchor points. It
makes sure it helps prevent over fitting.
So that's how we calculate the input gate.
And that calculation has nothing to
do with the rest of the other three
calculations.
Yet these are all the calculus
calculations that basically
they're using the previous output and the
current input and there's summing them
together to, to, to, uh,
to represent how data
has changed over time.
Now that we have these four,
these four,
yeah,
essentially,
uh, primitives that we've created the
input for gay output and memory cell.
Now we can combine them all together.
And so this is that last equation.
This is how we combine them together.
We take the four get date,
we multiply it by the current state,
and then we add it to the
input gate times the memory,
still times the memory cell. So the, the,
the state right here is the given state,
uh,
where we are currently and the memory
cells is the state where we were before.
So we take the input gate time,
what we remembered before,
plus the forget gate times what we
now get because the F and why are we
multiplying it because we want to see it.
What do we want to forget from what
we're given and then what do we want to
remember from what
we've stored previously.
And that output is going to give us a
final state and we're going to take that
state value and we're going to squash
it with a nonlinearity, with a,
with a non linearity.
And the nonlinearity is going to be Tan h,
which is a hyperbolic tangent of x.
Uh,
which essentially we don't
have to get into the details.
It is one of many nonlinearities.
But what it does here is it squashes
it into a probability value.
That means that converts the state,
whatever. It's, whatever it is,
a floating point number into a
single probability value. And uh,
we're gonna multiply it by the output
gate and that's going to be our output.
And at the end we were turned our,
our final output of the Lstm
cell and oh, sorry, the final,
not sorry,
the final state of the OCM and then
the output value that it calculates.
So that's what that's going to do.
And then,
yeah,
let me know when you want
to take questions. We have
some, we have some questions.
Yeah, go for the questions. So,
um, Kevin Nelson was asking,
can you use tensorflow to visualize
the network at some point or Nah,
I think that might've been a little bit
far back and Praveen just ask was it
raspberry pi or on tense would flow.
Okay. So Kyi, Kevin's question.
Let me paste this in and I'm going
to explain it to Kevin's question.
Can we use tensorflow to visualize
it? Yes. With tensor board,
which I'm sure you know, we, I need
to use tensor board more often.
Thank you for the reminder.
We're not doing it this time,
but we will in the future.
In fact,
I'm probably going to have
a tensor board specific.
Okay.
Live stream coming up soon. So, and
then Praveen and Praveen was asking,
um,
if the raspberry Pi on transfer flow,
and there's people now having
conversations about raspberry,
raspberry pie on tens of floods.
So I'm pretty sure that somebody
made a tensorflow raspberry Pi a
rapper. So there it is.
Yeah,
there it is. So here we go
with this. So back to this,
we want to now,
uh,
calculate the LSTM value over time.
So this is our unrolling over time.
So before we start training,
we want to feed it in all of those
values so that we can compute that those
longterm dependencies.
And this is what's happening here.
We're going to start off with an
empty set of matrices for our,
our output in our state. And then we're
going to unroll the LSTM loop over time.
So what does this mean?
So for each section we're going to
calculate a state and an output from our
LSTM. So to start off with, when
I equals zero, the first round,
we're going to give it into our,
give it to our outputs.
All I list, this is a list of outputs
that we are storing over time.
And this is our labels list
So once we're past that initial iteration,
then we can start,
uh, concatenating vectors
along a dimension access.
So we're not multiplying,
we're just adding in all of those
outputs and all of those labels.
Until finally at the last iteration,
we, we have our final value.
Okay.
And so,
okay, so then up to the
optimizer part, we're going to be
okay. So I'm going to paste this in
as well. So then for their classifier,
our classifier is, is, is,
is only gonna run after our saved
output and save state were assigned.
What does that mean? We have our list
of outputs. We have our list of states.
I will show a demo at the end.
Uh,
so
now that we have our LSTM
unrolled over time, that the dope,
the LSTM cell is the only thing that
we really, that we worry about in our,
in an LSTM network, we just needed to
find the LSTM cell. And then we have, uh,
the weights from cells,
plural.
And then we have the weights from the
hidden layer of LSTM cells to the output
layer.
And that's what we're defining here,
that last set of weights for the bigger
network in and of itself, not the cells,
but the bigger network and to those are
defined by WNB and they're generated
randomly using the
truncated normal function.
And then we're going to
calculate the logics.
So logics is so largest is uh,
the,
the function that operates on the
unscaled output of earlier layers.
So it's a way for us to
think about, uh, what,
uh,
what is going to be that,
that value that we feed to
our loss function. Okay.
So it is our prediction
outputs. It's a, it's a,
it's a list of all of our predicted
outputs and we're going to compare it with
the labels.
So we have predictions.
And then we have our labels
and then we want to minimize.
So he had predicted characters
and then actual characters.
And we'll minimize the loss using
cross entropy with low budgets.
So why are we using cross entropy?
Because Cross entropy,
a good optimizer for,
uh,
multi-class classification, which is
what this is. We have a question from go.
Cool. Who's seeing many
people you normally use relo?
Why use sigmoid or Tan and the
reasons? Uh, good question. Uh,
so [inaudible] is 10.
It is becoming more popular these days.
Uh, why use raw over tan? Uh,
that's a good question. In fact,
I should have a video comparing different
activation functions and when and why
you should use them. In this case,
we're not using rally Lou because,
uh, the Tan function
because we're using, uh,
a softmax specifically because we're using
softmax cross entropy for multi-class
classification. Generally, uh,
10 h is paired with
multi-class classification,
whereas rail Relo is, uh, with,
sorry, Tan h is with multi-class
classification for recurrent networks,
whereas [inaudible] is more often
used for convolutional networks.
We have seen them in recurrent networks,
uh,
but they're mostly used for
convolutional networks. And, uh,
I'm actually gonna have a
video coming out on that soon.
Then we're going to use the reduced
mean function to calculate the average
probability.
And that is our loss.
So given all of those probabilities
across the list of possible characters,
we're going to compute the average.
Okay.
And then we're going to that as our
loss and that is a loss that we want to
minimize using gradient descent,
given our global step values that
keeps track of all of the, uh,
values. Okay. So then we're going to,
sorry.
So then we're going to train our model
to here. Is it for our training step?
Hold on. So let me make sure
this is all good. So online hate,
batch size,
char size.
Hold on.
Okay. So here's what it is. It's sad.
Tf Low 32 batch size charts
has invalid syntax because?
Because
it is an omnium. See how many
people are here right now?
Okay. Three and four. Nine.
Good. So we have an invalid batch
size and an invalid char size. And,
uh, oh right. There we go.
Great.
Great. Okay, so now for our training
step, so I'm going to paste this in. Uh,
so here's how, here's how it's going to
work. Uh, so we have our graph. Okay.
And we're going to first
initialize our variables.
So this is our global variable and then
an offset value that I'm going to talk
about. Their real, we got to,
the real things to talk about here
is the offset value and then a saver.
Cause we're going to just save
our model every so often. Okay.
And uh, so for each of our training
steps, for each of our training steps,
we're going to start off as zero.
So this is our actual training steps.
We are going to feed it in as batches.
We are data and labels that we feed
in as batches and the offset helps us
calculate what those batches are going to
be, the size of those batches. Okay. And,
and there's, there's a calm next to
bat size that you're missing. Yeah,
I added that.
Thanks.
Okay.
Up there. Uh, and so,
okay,
we want to feed it to the
model model iteratively.
So for the first part we'll calculate
those batches and the labels.
We'll update the offset until,
and we're using that offset to make sure
that we have the right data at the end,
uh, at the very end right here. Okay.
And then we're going to optimize it with
our loss function and then we're going
to feed it in as dictionaries,
batch data, batch labels in batches.
We get our training loss,
uh,
and we and the run functions going to
run our optimizer given our loss. Right?
And it's going to every step.
And then remember that those that's saved.
Every variable we use to to uh,
okay.
Calculate that.
So
think there might be a semi colon that's
needed. It's what people are saying.
Okay.
Where though, tell us
where it guys, hold on.
Do you have to have variables?
Initializer yeah, coming up on our,
on the album coming up on the
hour, coming up on the hour. Okay.
initializer.run.
You're not actually,
let's move this for a second. So, okay.
So this is actually going to take a while
to train. We're running up on the hour.
Let's, what did I have trained right
here? So, so here's what happened.
So when I give it this,
so here's the demo and then we're going,
I'm going to show more demo code.
Uh, so when I give it this value,
I plan to make the world a better place.
It's going to initialize the
graph and load the model.
So for every character
in the input sentence,
it's going to generate the next
character for every character is going to
generate.
Then the next character and okay,
so it's character out of character,
character out of character at a time.
So this is actually pretty bad right here.
Why? Because I trained it for one
iteration before I started this session.
I plan to make the world a better
place by off, I guess parts. It's act,
it looks like Latin because we are
generating it with one iteration.
But what happens when we generate
it with lots of iterations? Okay,
here's the demo of what happens
when we generate it with this exact,
this exact code,
this exact type of code and LSTM network.
When we generate lots of iterations and
you can see what happens over time here.
Uh, where is it? Hold on. Come
on baby. Here's what it is.
So the evolution of samples,
while training is a good example.
So it's just like this, right? Just
like what I've just showed right here.
It starts off really bad like this.
And then with each iteration at 308 or so,
that was at 100 iterations.
At 300 iterations, it's more like two
hours. At 500, it's more like five hours.
And I'm talking about on a CPU that's
like 2.4 gigahertz and then 700 it gets
better and better. And by 2000
iterations it is amazing. Okay.
It gets better at spelling, it gets better
at everything. That's it for our code.
Uh, and the, uh, linked to that
is in the description and so yeah,
last five minute Q and a and
then we're done for the day.
Okay.
Qa time. Yes. And a time. Cool.
So we have a couple of things people
were asking about different live streams
that you want you're planning to do.
So party was asking you if
you're going to do a drone,
a drone image, trucking
livestream, and uh,
Ozzie Campos asking if you're going
to do a stream of bought seek to seek,
seek to suite. The sequencing
was, yeah. So for the drone,
that's going to be the robot video.
I'll do a drone video soon. Yeah.
For sequence a sequence. That's what I'm
in right now. Like I'm in the sequence,
the sequence world. We, we
made a sequence, the sequence,
I made a sequence sequence video last
week. I'm making one this weekend.
I'm going to make one next
week for chatbots. So yeah,
that's different sequences.
The sequence. Are you a human or AI?
I am a human. I am a human for now.
Neil Neil Sandy said
something really cool.
He says it's a great way to
build confidence is through
your math pep talk that
you give. So that's shout out to
you. Oh yes. Thank you Neil. Yes,
math is just the language
voice shop. Ya. Uh,
asked earlier if you could please do an
outline of the program at the end cause
he was kind of losing track of how you're
yeah, let me do it. Ending outline.
Great. Any other questions before I do
the outline? Um, I think that's about,
that's the good stuff.
Okay. So here's the outline.
We started off with our dependencies.
This is a fast outline and
then we imported our tax,
that's Wikipedia text and we said,
let's look at let's store only the unique
characters because we want to generate
unique characters so that we can have
these two dictionaries to map the
characters to ids and an ids to characters
so that we can use that later on, uh,
for training. Then we grow, uh, uh,
a sample method to generate
the probability of each
next character given the
predicted value for that
comes out of our model.
We vectorize our data using non pie that
we fed in and these are 50 character
long sentences. We fed
it into our model. Okay.
And our model is an LSTM network and
LSTM network has an input gate. Uh,
forget gate on Applegate and in memory
cell. We unrolled it through time.
Okay. Before, before we
unrolled it through time,
we wrote up the equations for that.
How data on how data flow through
an LSTM cell and rapid. Okay.
Hold on.
No sleep. That's exactly my life.
No sleep. So that's a perfect beat.
How has the ship, oh, check your check
your sound settings on your laptop.
So go gutter system profits.
Oh my God. Okay. Stupid.
See I will gladly rapid because we were
in the last two minutes. So let me just,
if the Internet decides to work,
could you just play some rap?
Like some hip hop beat? Yeah.
Like if this just starts.
Okay.
Um,
just whatever.
Okay.
And the notebook has in the description.
Okay. So the notebook is
in the description and a
want to get a ration before I started
this session. Oh, that's violence.
To make the world a better place.
Does any good. Okay. No,
stop that. Stop that.
Okay. Here we go. We're, we're, we,
we took our LSTM state. We
David and input date, we get up,
forget gate, we David and how cook
cakes. I'm David a memory cell.
I calculated that output state.
I took the forget gate and
multiplied by the state,
I give it an input gate and
give it a memory sale. Yo.
And then I got that output value.
I got an output state output and a state.
That's what I did for my LSTM cell.
I calculated my hair's always either.
I unrolled it through time.
I was saying,
here are all my outputs and here are
my labels. Calculate it in the sale,
man.
I'm like Charles babble.
I got a classifier given all of
those cells unroll through time.
I had our weights and our biases.
Man,
I'm going online with 350 people live.
I got my loss function,
um, minimized. It would cross
entropy. Ah, this is my function.
I optimize gradient descent.
Man, I'm online all the time.
At the end I ran my training function
given the states that came back,
we brought back,
propagate it through time.
And then at the end we calculated our
training loss. We optimize, we optimize.
All right. Hey, hey, here we go. Yo.
That's how we did. We saved the model.
All right though. We saved it every day.
I'm going crazy. I love rapping, man.
It's my day today.
Okay. Yeah. So hype man.
Let's give him some love at buddy
does these kinds of streams
where they show machine learned,
they teach machine learning and they
stream at the same time and they wrap.
That's pretty amazing.
Thank you. Wizard of Oz coming at you. We
are. I am here at the upload VR studios,
so thanks everybody for watching
this livestream, uh, for being here.
I'm going to show the,
I'm going to show that code and
the code is in the description.
I'm going to add comments and read me.
Stop to it within the hour.
Thanks for coming guys. I love
you guys. A little, five less,
five more shout outs to names.
Sal Load. Javier Anthony,
a good CEO. Anthony Sparks,
sporanox and James. Hey James.
Good to see you. All right. Uh,
for now I've got to go practice my,
uh,
everything because I want to get better
at everything. Bigger, better, faster,
stronger. Uh, so for, that's what I've
got to do. So thanks for watching.
Ooh.
[inaudible].